you've seen her colorful meals all over
Tick Tock maybe you've done one of her
workouts online Anna is a 27 year old
certified trainer turned YouTuber and
tick tocker with a fitness app grow with
Anna her workouts are no joke but her
approach is gentle and accessible and
with nearly 3 million subscribers people
are clearly loving the pays but what
does a dietitian think of her diet let's
check out everything that Anna eats in a
day hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
today we'll be taking a look at the diet
of YouTuber and Tick Tock sensation Anna
from grow with ananas but first please
check out my disclaimer that we will be
looking at someone's die in detail so
please feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you're new here subscribe to that
channel and hit that follow button
please help a girl out and also follow
me on Tick Tock and Instagram at Abby's
kitchen and since we're talking about
Fitness today let me tell you quickly
about my sponsor co-pilot so co-pilot is
a one-on-one Fitness experience that
combines quality coaching with
technology to help you reach your own
personal fitness goals at your own pace
you fill out your survey they match with
a coach and you set up your fitness
goals and plan if you use your Apple
watch the system will automatically
track your sets pacing and range of
motion and your coach will be with you
to guide you through but even if you
don't own an Apple Watch it is such a
great workout for on the go your coach
will work with whatever equipment and
space you have and whatever time you
have available so it's ideal for folks
with chaotic schedules like me or when
I'm traveling and not with my gear at
home I've been working with Justin who
is a real person not just like an app or
AI who I've met with virtually to
discuss my goals at Fitness level and
time commitment he then creates real
video workouts uniquely for me at
scheduled times in the week and he can
track my activity and send me lots of
tips videos for form and of course
motivation through the app I literally
have all the benefits of in-person
training working with Justin but with a
lot more convenience safety and a more
reasonable price in a world that's
becoming progressively more and more
virtual this really is the most
efficient and effective way to work out
so if you want to try out co-pilot
yourself check out my link in the
description to get 14 days free with
your own Fitness coach it has been a hot
moment since I've done an OG Abby's
kitchen YouTuber what I in a day review
I am feeling nostalgic right now for a
moment but yeah I've gotten so many
requests to talk about growing ananas
and as a follower myself I was like
hell's yes give me a hell yeah
I can do that now Anna doesn't have any
recent full length what Aina days so I
pulled these four video examples from
her shorts slash Tick Tock content that
she shared online so let's take a look
at breakfast okay love The Eclectic
options here and I specifically like
that she's not shying away from morning
carbs well I don't think that the
average person needs to obsess over the
timing of like different macros in the
day it's worth pointing out that it
metabolically does make sense to like
front load a lot of your carbs in the
morning when our body is more insulin
sensitive of all the options I would say
the Chia protein pudding is likely the
most balanced and satiating because we
got lots of healthy fats in the Chia app
protein in the milk and the yogurt and
fiber rich carbs in the berries on top
but I also love the idea of the leftover
pasta salad as proof that there's no
such thing as designated breakfast foods
I would probably try adding in some like
leftover chicken or tofu or beans in the
salad since I know that there are a lot
of benefits to getting protein in that
first morning meal also the driving and
centrally aesthetic eating while filming
definitely gives me major anxiety but
otherwise lots of delicious morning
inspo here let's talk about exercise so
according to a lot of her Vlogs her
movement for the day is either shooting
a workout for her YouTube video or going
on like a hot girl walk or as many
Fitness vloggers do possibly both maybe
I'm just old but is it only an official
hot girl walk when you film it from the
chest down I don't know asking for a
friend
but anyways I really do enjoy Honest
YouTube workouts I think she's super
encouraging inclusive and doesn't seem
to be pushing any kind of toxic weight
loss diet culture in fact I love what
she said in this Tick Tock right here
[Music]
that my friends is the truth you can't
handle the truth this may or may not be
disappointing to hear for a lot of you
gym bunnies but exercise is not the best
way to lose weight actually it's a
pretty shitty way to lose weight if we
want to put this into context our
caloric intake is made up a hundred
percent of the food that we eat but your
daily physical activity only makes up
about 10 to 30 percent of our caloric
expenditure and only a small subset of
that is intentional exercise our body
also has a ton of compensatory
mechanisms in place to conserve energy
and maintain energy balance so for
example we tend to eat more after
exercise and unconsciously move less
just doing basic acts of living on the
flip side we know that exercise has a
myriad of benefits that are way more
significant than weight loss it can
improve mood energy levels cognition
Sleep Quality regularity bone health and
even blood markers like cholesterol and
blood pressure so yeah exercise just
really needs to be rebranded as
something we do for health and pleasure
not to change our weight alright lovers
let's get into lunch
baby when you're done
gotta be the first okay so as usual I
love the variety here lots of great
colorful veggies a nice combination of
plant-based and animal-based proteins
and a variety of different carbs it's
clear that she doesn't cut out Foods or
food groups because there are so many
great looking ingredients in her
repertoire and this really is key since
Risa suggests that die diversity is
really important to a healthy gut which
in turn means a healthy mind immune
system weight digestive system and so
much more and more specifically this
largely comes down to fiber diversity
when it comes to fiber we got Prebiotic
fiber resistant starches and other
insoluble and soluble fibers and
different bacteria strains prefer
different fibers so if you're only
getting your fiber from like one source
like wheat for example you're not giving
different bacteria in your microbiome an
opportunity to flourish and grow so how
many different foods should we all be
focusing on well a recent recommending
aiming for 30 different plant-based
Foods per week so that means switching
up different grains veggies pulses nuts
and seeds to give your gut the ultimate
shot at thriving I love making chickpea
salad sandwiches myself so simple and
inexpensive to pull off yet so packed
with saturating fiber and protein and if
you want to up the satiety Factor even
more you can smash a little avocado in
there as well in fact that's usually how
I make my avocado toast I basically
puree together avocado with some white
beans and it yields a higher protein
super creamy avocado topping
see avocado toast and then of course I
load up on everything but the bagel
seasoning
honestly it's just so refreshing to see
a Creator eating carbs and fats or like
not adding any pseudoscience ingredients
or supplements or explanations why they
do or don't eat something I mean it's
kind of sad that I have to congratulate
someone like this but Tis the times all
right let's take a look at some snacks
okay I love these options and of course
I'm biased because they kind of seem
like snacks I would make for myself just
saying we generally have some great
hunger crushing combos here with
approaching the yogurt and bar fiber and
the berries and cereal and healthy fats
in the peanut butter I'm not sure what
yogurt she's using because often these
clips kind of go by so quick but I am
personally a fan of full fat and I'm
gonna tell you why number one it's
objectively healthier in a lot of ways
we have tons of research that choosing
full fat Dairy is linked to lower risk
of heart disease diabetes and maybe
better for folks with insulin resistance
and PCOS likely because the added fat
helps to buffer the natural sugars and
also because of the protective effects
of some unique fatty acids in Dairy
number two it's more satiating that is
more saching than carbs so when we have
a greater percentage of calories coming
from fats versus natural sugars AKA
lactose we're gonna feel Fuller for
longer three If you're lactose
intolerant It generally is easier to
digest since again the fat buffers and
edges out some of the lactose and four
it just tastes better at least to my
palate healthy food is only healthy if
you actually eat it and I personally
find fat-free yogurt kind of like two
astringent thin and Bland and I end up
having to add a lot more sugar to make
it palatable and as we established sugar
is not shading as bad but let me know in
the comments below what your thoughts
are all right moving on to dinner I am
all for these super simple quickie meals
[Music]
okay the roasted tofu and veg dinner
with Greek yogurt dip looks low-key
amazing and the lettuce wraps with chips
and guac on the side hello I'm here for
it hello and I think that Anna's dinner
is here prove that a healthy balanced
meal doesn't have to mean meat carbs veg
like if she's having tortilla chips on
the side with her guac she loads her
taco meat into a lettuce wrap instead if
she's having a leftover platter of veg
avocado cheese and some dips she serves
some crackers on the side you don't just
have to eat quinoa and sweet potatoes to
have a healthy balanced dinner idea and
speaking of balanced meals again Anna
and I are kind of Kindred food Spirits
because her post dinner snacks basically
look like mine but way more
instagramable I usually just Chuck some
things together in a bowl and they never
look like that especially the dark
chocolate yogurt cup like who has time
for that before bed ain't nobody got
time for that that said it seems like we
generally are enjoying a beautiful
combination of protein Rich yogurt and
fruit before bed with a little chocolate
thrown in for good measure but yeah I
think yogurt and fruit are a great snack
combination thanks to the protein and
fiber combo and while the research
results have been mixed they may also
specifically be great for Sleep Teresa
suggests that Dairy before bed may help
to reduce the time it takes to fall
asleep and waking frequency along with
improving sleep efficiency and sleep
duration and this is probably because
the calcium and dairy helps the brain
use tryptophan which helps to support
the sleep hormone melatonin we also know
that having a solid dose of protein at
bedtime can help to support satiety
which can prevent weight cups and also
helps to stabilize blood sugars which is
also important for Quality sleep so yeah
these our insomnia approved options
right here generally speaking I think
honest content is refreshingly well
balanced and supportive I love that she
doesn't demonize any specific Foods or
food groups and I honestly haven't seen
any pseudoscience nutrition claims
either Bravo
foreign
s are also beautifully well balanced
nourishing non-restrictive and also
relatively easily accessible most
Wellness influencers meals are padded
with countless bogus supplements and
overpriced over hype superfoods that
seem to kind of be included more as a
financial Flex than for any kind of
legitimate nutrition support but Anna
keeps it simple and as a result I
actually believe that she probably does
eat like this in real life and not just
for show I think it's really easy to get
caught up in Wellness influencers
perfectly styled what I in a days and
think that you're not healthy if you're
not eating overpriced nourish bowls
every day of the week but if your quest
for physical health and dietary Purity
is becoming obsessive and overshadowing
opportunities for True pleasure
spontaneity and social experiences like
the things that make us human it's not
adding to your health it's robbing you
of it so I think this is a good reminder
that a healthy diet must include
consideration for emotional and social
well-being as well because
nobody wants to end up so fearful of
food that they subsist on an IV drip
just to survive now I want to call this
an ick because I think that's kind of a
mean term but the only thing that kind
of gives me pause while watching some of
honest content is the occasional body
check I don't see it often like I don't
think that this is a body check as much
as a woman just wearing a cute crop top
but this one for example is what I would
call a pretty direct body check and you
know what I don't have an issue with
people making videos about their flat
stomachs if that's the purpose of the
video it's not something that I want to
watch and I do think it can be
triggering for a lot of people but I do
think it's also up to each individual to
kind of screen the content they consume
ditto for before and after shots which I
found on our website it's not something
I personally like and I do think that
this is a bit at odds with her don't
exercise for Aesthetics messaging but I
don't know as I get older and maybe a
little bit more tired of this app I just
have to see things like this for what
they are and thin bodies sell programs
and get clicks so I'm going to put that
aside for a second as an unfortunate
Hazard of the trade in the fitness space
that said I do continually strongly take
issue with body checks at the start of
what I eat a day videos because they
insinuate that if you eat like this you
can look like this and you don't have to
spell that out for that message to be
heard I don't think that this was Anna's
intention like I'm sure she knows that
when she shares images of her beautiful
body that more people will like click
and follow but just seeing how
thoughtful she generally is sharing
weight neutral messages around balanced
gender nutrition and exercise I
admittedly was a little bit surprised to
see body checks like that on his
audience not on like mine are likely
more vulnerable to making these
dangerous diet equals body connections
and this is not to embarrass or slam
Anna like all of us content creators are
human and we really cannot nail every
piece of content every time I also make
mistakes in delivery that I regret but
this is just some feedback and some
gentle food for future thought whatever
that means and don't forget to check out
copilot yourself to start your fitness
journey today I love that this app isn't
weight focused offers lots of
personalized one-on-one interaction with
your coach and is designed to help you
reach your goals at your own pace so hit
up the description to get 14 days free
with your own Fitness coach and on that
note that is all that I have for you
guys today if you like this video please
be sure to give it a thumbs up leave me
a comment below with your thoughts
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye